good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day
that's right it's hump day dude is here
jackie's here i'm here little camper's
here we're all [ __ ] here we're all
[ __ ] here i'm here too uh i'd like to
see how long you can go i know before i
can get a word in and you know what i
did say jackie's here you did so i think
people knew and i'm just so excited to
be back in the studio back
back
you know i actually think i know people
hate the singing i don't want to get
into it but i do think like every time
you and i
sing like you do get better at singing
like where we started to where we are
now like you are a much better singer
thank you so much i i didn't know i was
going to be showered with compliments
this morning that's what i do it means
so much to hear that from you and i just
wanted to say i'm so excited to be
obviously back in the studio on a
wednesday
with doo doo doo celebrating hump day it
feels like
the the nature is healing the universe
is aligning i completely agree there's
so much so much going on that got us
here today and as usual it's so
important that we acknowledge the space
that we're currently in so yes it's hump
day me and theo have humped jackie will
be doing the humping after you also look
so pregnant today it's crazy like can
you just poke out your belly show
everyone yeah i mean without getting up
it's hard but like no it's there you can
see yeah like i went away for a week and
you can't and like you're like it grew
yeah yeah that's what happens no totally
and also i feel like maybe correct me if
i'm wrong when you show up to the show
it's like the smallest your belly's
gonna be that day it gets bigger as the
day goes on it gets bigger as i eat yeah
not like
noticeably but i can notice it yeah um
okay well we're back i'm so excited hope
everyone enjoyed yesterday's podcast
only episode i for one did enjoy it i
enjoyed it if you were waiting for us to
come back into the studio make sure to
check out yesterday's episode because we
left it all on the episode there was so
much to unload there was so much to
unload and i feel so good because up
until then we recorded i was just like
thinking about came on snl
now it's like fresh tabula rasa what
clean slate that's what that means
say it again tabula rasa i think it's
latin
honestly i learned that term
i never learned latin no but like it's
like a uh you know a school ting i
prefer to speak gibberish
in the guy
in the gov
that means i love you
okay what was it called tabula rosa
tabula rasa
i feel like no one's going to know what
you're talking about ancient greek
philosophy is tabular asses the theory
that individuals are born without
built-in mental content and therefore
aren't all knowledge comes from
experience or perception fresh place so
like a clean slate this isn't my flight
template this is not my job
we have an amazing show you guys it's
hump day our spirits are high thea was
here just injecting our veins in you
know with delicious love
and also the pre-sale for my tour star
it's not like other girls i'm going back
on tour at the end of this year tickets
go on sale on friday but
if you're a patreon member which
hopefully most of you are you get access
to the pre-sale so the pre-sale starts
today at noon if you're looking for the
ticket links and the pre-sale codes they
will be on patreon.com morning toast or
if you have the app all of them will be
posted at noon eastern time today it is
wednesday i'm so excited to see you guys
on tour i'm very much looking forward to
just like traveling seeing the gals
again seeing you know the husband's
being dragged um it's going to be
a tabula rosa event yeah it's going to
be amazing tour starts in december
december 2nd i'm starting off in
minneapolis which i just have to say
like that was unplanned minneapolis is a
great place yeah i had a fabulous time
last time i was there and we went there
for the super bowl yes it was so [ __ ]
cold oh my god it was so cold but we
still have a great time but i've heard
i've heard that the minneapolis summers
are like something to say but you're
going in december yeah so i'll bring my
code so you didn't plan well for that no
not at all um but it's so by the way
booking a tour after cobit is [ __ ]
impossible like everyone's competing for
these venues everyone is competing for
dates everyone wants a weekend that's
why it took me so long but i actually
think like i needed the time i'm very
i'm very pleased with how it's turned
out so i'm hitting up all the places
we're going to florida california
atlanta houston all the places so check
it out it's called the not like other
girls tour and tickets if you're not a
patreon member will be available on
friday but there are limited vip tickets
because of covid so i just feel like
it's better safe than sorry it's good to
keep that all in mind when you're
logging on at 12 p.m eastern time to the
patreon to hit up the pre-sale totally
so
that is my personal promotion for the
day i'll be done i think i'll end it
there also we have an amazing show you
guys because it's wednesday but we are
doing dear toasters because it was just
too crazy yesterday claudia insisted i
insisted we're going to do a bridge
version because you know that's called
compromise jackie doesn't like like if
we happen to miss something on a tuesday
she will wait till next tuesday for the
most part i agree with that especially
as it pertains to the tv recap segment
but dear toads like what we should go a
whole week that why are we gonna punish
our waiting for our advice they're
waiting and you know so i we're gonna do
two submissions today not three that way
i feel like it's a good compromise okay
that's good i feel good about that plus
we have so much to discuss today just
more news i have i feel like i have a
lot to share but i also need to know
because you posted last night on your
story that you finally watched blended
on the plane i was just gonna bring that
up okay um i need to hear your review i
didn't even realize that i talk about it
that much but i do whenever we talk
about people like getting married with
kids like you always bring up that movie
and they say they should watch it and
you know what i didn't realize that like
i knew that the the film was going to be
about like a blended family obviously
because it's called blended but i didn't
know that like the the concept of a
blended family would be like the
backbone of this film yeah so let me
just say i absolutely adored the movie i
thought it was hysterical
funny bella thorne was hysterical like
the fact that like
there his wife had passed away so adam
sandler like just all of his kids he
took them to their barber which made me
laugh because when we were kids like one
time our dad took olivia to me and you
to his barber like for a haircut like
dads just don't think they're just like
haircut yeah olivia came home
with an actual like i don't know a
pyramid yeah it was a triangle haircut
it was we were all foreign
yes
oh my god so when that was like why
bella thorne's hair was like that i was
cracking up so i loved the movie i do
have to say
it was almost ruined by the horrendous
acting from drew barrymore like she
should honestly be embarrassed like it
was her worst work yet by far she was
giving me community theater her acting
was so unbelievably bad but a few things
saved it one adam sandler is like so
endearing and so charming and it was
just you know like he like probably like
he was just great wendy mcclendon covey
if she's in a film or a tv show like a
plus like i'm watching it she was
hysterical i agree and then shaq was
there
it was just family fun for all with a
beautiful message but it was also like
so funny and it just i feel like it's
just so much better than it they
probably set out for it to be yeah and
like i don't think it's regarded as like
you know there's adam sandler went
through like this stage where he just
made like the most amazing movies like
spanglish and click like and he is like
what is an amazing movie that's like
probably his most famous movie no
big daddy that's what i was water boy
but no like
billy madison you don't respect the
click um i only watched it once because
it was so long but i got the point he
had a clicker
that is what happened but for sure um
and it was just a lot like i think you
should re-watch it actually like i think
it's like it's the most beautiful movie
like it's really gorgeous yeah okay i
mean since you are a blended file like i
am i'm a blendophile
i will respect your opinions so what i
was thinking was like he hadn't made a
movie in a while like i feel like his
best work was behind him and i just
never saw blended because i'm like okay
dumb you know adam sandler movie
gorgeous absolutely
gorgeous i'm so glad to hear that and so
great to watch on a plane it's actually
like a long movie so it was like two
hours the flight was three hours it was
perfect like i had dinner while i
watched it was really
gorgeous i'm
this warms my heart yeah and you know
and like i am sort of
weary
with things you become obsessed with
because sometimes you become obsessed
with things like just because like you
want to not because like you love them
so much you know what i mean i hear you
can you cite an example well yeah a bad
teacher
stop you can't stop i love that teacher
so much and you know what it wasn't
until i had seen it so many times where
i realized how much i love the movie
like when it first came out i i wasn't
like i don't think i saw it in theaters
you know it just like grew on me in such
a profound way can i ask you a question
you made me watch
bad teacher what did i think about it
what was my review did you like it you
were fine with it but you didn't love it
to the degree that i did whatsoever okay
whatsoever um so yes i did watch blended
thank you for bringing that film into my
life i would love to watch it again like
not with shitty headphones on an
airplane like in a proper ex like
viewing experience i'm just so happy to
hear that thank you so much for
that was just so exciting to see you i
saw your story that you tagged me in
something you're like jackie's always
talking about this movie i guess i'll
watch it i'm like what [ __ ] movie am
i always talking about that you haven't
seen and it was blended i was like [ __ ]
yeah you literally talk about it all the
time yeah you know when two celebrities
get together and they have kids i do
recommend
that the kids watch
oh and terry crews was just
everything
that's literally me like walking around
on people being like we're blending like
just singing like he was so good and
funny like it was a great movie
fun for the whole family the whole
blended family exactly okay well i have
a personal life update which is that i
finished jane eyre last night thank god
i know you know what i went to bed last
night
and i was at 83 and i just plowed
through i was like i gotta find out what
happened it got really low for a second
and then the end was really sweet and
overall like i said on the podcast
yesterday
i won't be doing that again and you know
what you did i wish you literally
listened to tick tocks because you girl
bossed a little too close to the sun
like you just took it a little too far
that's a really funny term yeah it's
like i don't want another thing but i
think i may have grown boston a little
too close to the sun that's so funny
what do people say about you know like
when you apply for like a ceo job as
like a 17 year old and they write you
back like looking for an interview on
linkedin oh that's that's such a funny
thing phrase yeah love to see tick tock
being funny so i've been trying to tell
you so i've been trying to tell you okay
well other than that
i think we should get into everything i
did watch vanderpump rules last night so
i'll recap it a little bit at the end
because
i don't think i don't think you should
watch it because it
it had
some highs
but some low lows and just this season
is just it's not it it's not it no and i
keep seeing you know
tom and tom just launched a um like a
whiskey or something okay scotch
something like that and i just feel like
they're all kind of flocking now to like
milk the i don't think there's going to
be more than like three seasons left
i think they're all just like kind
trying to make the most out of what's to
come because i do think the end is near
yeah it's it's getting rough so we'll do
a quick lethal recap at the end but i
think without further ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
a peacock original one of us is lying
sounds spooky five students walk into
detention and only four walk out alive
follow the story based on the number one
new york times bestseller one of us is
lying now a peacock original on the
first day of school yale said bronwyn
baseball star cooper cheerleader addie
and drug dealing nate all land
themselves in detention with notorious
gossip blogger simon when one of them
doesn't make it out alive everyone
becomes a suspect each with their with
their own secrets and motives this juicy
teen drama takes unexpected new twists
as we find out who's hiding
what in this can't miss new series with
romance betrayal secrecy and more one of
us is lying is the murder mystery of the
season so don't miss one of us is lying
streaming now only on peacock go to
peacocktv.com to get started
thank you so much claudia our first
story is it's a pleasure it's some crazy
food news cfa oh
bobby flay is out at the food network
after 27 years
so i like to think we had a little
something to do with this okay
reports are saying people magazine is
reporting via source that bobby flay
wanted a 100 million dollar contract to
stay with the food network and that's
nuts split is strictly business who does
he think he is guy fieri no literally he
what that's what they're saying he
wanted more than guy fieri what we
reported that guy thierry got like the
highest million dollars got it and he
wanted a hundred million dollars to go
around and bully people and ambush them
in their homes their recipes weren't
enough okay so here's the thing i think
i read something i think it was on dumas
that yes there's like a big thing coming
with bobby like i don't think it's about
yes the money that there's like a
scandal coming well it's a blind item
and so you assume it's about bobby it's
about a big tv chef who ambushes people
in their hometowns and he's like i can
make a better chili
um and i'm like let's make a patreon
and
duma blind item said that you know
there's something big brewing so maybe
this source is just doing some damage
control and maybe he also did 100
million dollars but they're like you're
not worth 100 million dollars and you're
trouble right yeah they smelled the
trouble and they're like bobby
you've been chopped bobby is cooking up
trouble he's constantly stirring the pot
so i mean we could go on with these
there are so many other
food networks that are not the food
network and you know streamers and this
and that so are there yes like discovery
plus
okay so there's new networks yeah
they're all and i watched a lot of
magnolia table so i watched so much tv
while
we were off and the whole time i was
like having a pics i'm like i'm not
watching anything that's like productive
for the show like i should be watching
squid games you know yeah you should i
couldn't bring myself to do it i was
just watching like irrelevant stuff but
magnolia table is so [ __ ] good she's
literally a gem and a half she's such a
queen her food looks so delicious but is
it food network discovery
is it or is it scripts
i believe
scripps was bought by discovery it's too
confusing no i'm pretty sure they're all
like all the food places are owned by
the same and like the cooking channel
yeah no this is making sense yeah so
they're all really under one roof so i
don't know where you go after the food
network if you're gonna leave that
discovery plus
bubble but you know what i just i do
feel like
it's not his time anymore like i've
really i think there are so many amazing
personalities that come on food network
and i just don't feel like i feel like
bobby flay is part of this like older
generation
of like boring i just he doesn't do it
for me anymore like he's no guy fieri
like i fear he is oozing with
personality literally it's coming out of
every orifice in his body
food literally in the best way possible
and bobby flay's just kind of meh i'm
sorry 100 million is so not what he's
worth i don't know i just feel like his
days are are numbered in my opinion like
you got your restaurants why don't you
just retire
yeah it reminds me of that like rachel
ray paula dean era like
things have changed on the food network
yeah
that's true he's been there since 1994.
things have changed
food content has really changed yes you
know it's especially we talk about this
a lot on the food network it's much more
competitive
shows than it is like lifestyle
30-minute meals which is unfortunate
that's unfortunate because i think
30-minute meals and just rachel ray in
general
30-minute meals was the best thing to
happen to food network it was really
like this place for like you know moms
making dinner in a hurry like it was
just this everything like relatable she
was a queen with like her retro kitchen
like i don't know the stuff that they're
serving us now some of it's good i like
the seasonal stuff you know like
halloween spooky cake off but i don't
know so many competition shows you know
yeah even though i did spend the week
watching the great british bake off and
it's so amazing and by the end i was i
did have a tear in my eye i did
everything makes me emotional though it
doesn't really mean that much but it was
really beautiful well that's like
you are permanently like on a plane
yes with your pregnancy yes i cried at
the end of blended last night it was
beautiful
why not why not shed a tear oh and the
other thing about blended was that um
joel mchale was like the mean ex-husband
he is literally i don't think he's he
plays the same person and everything
like just like a dick you know yeah yeah
i would love to see him in a you know a
more earnest role okay just to see if he
can be like anything he's always just
like this sarcastic like prick yeah he's
like who he was on the soup
yeah
whatever happened to this super so well
he does i think cove it happened yeah i
think they just lumped it in with all
yeah with all the copic stuff so we're
wishing bobby the best with you know
looking forward to where he goes next i
feel like after the food network like
you really just retire you have all
these restaurants you think think of
like emerald i know but it's not
it's it's not stagnant like you need to
be on the tv for people to like go you
know yes but i think at some point like
if you're on tv for long enough like
emerald is not on tv anymore and he
still has all of his restaurants like
mario batali like i think that
bobby plays probably at that place where
he could literally just retire he has he
has you know steakhouses in atlantic
city in vegas those are cash machines
like just sit down go to sleep you know
yeah i mean i'm sure if you wanted to
stay at the food network
according to this article it just would
have taken less money yeah but like you
know he walked maybe bobby thinks that's
not worth his time yeah he should be
making 100 million to go ambush poor
people in their
in their hometowns yeah no i don't know
if he still does that anymore well in
this climate he shouldn't yeah i i yeah
i agree yeah
i read okay are you ready for our next
story
yeah for sure
because megan fox and machine gun kelly
are on the cover of gq just
explaining it all i am weed i am weed
megan fox says she saw her own soul's
reflection in machine gun kelly the self
report claimed twin flames didn't i you
network earlier well then why don't you
say anything because it's wrong no you
think that if you stop like correcting
me like i'll stop making fun of you and
i'm not so we might as well just like be
on the same wrong wrong okay the
self-proclaimed twin flames didn't hold
anything back while speaking to british
gq style for their joint autumn winter
2021 cover shoot the lovebirds reflected
on everything from their early days as a
couple to why they make the perfect
partners in crime well i thought the
photos before we get into the freakiness
of what they said i thought the photos
were really stunning i think machine gun
kelly is really like a great model you
know he like changes his hair he's open
to all these different creative things
the chameleon he's a chameleon i thought
the photos were gorgeous and obviously
she's like sickening looking yeah the
photos were stunning um they met
obviously as we know working on the film
midnight in the switchgrass following
her split from brian austin green who
got sent home on dancing with the stars
last night
with sharna and matt james
um megan said you know this is what my
heart was searching for famously like
i'm an unusual person i had buried a lot
of that because it didn't have a place
to live i recognized so much of myself
in him and vice versa and that locked up
part of me that i had put away
so they're sweet yeah there's some
sweetness there's also some twin flame
energy craziness yeah so i really like
these cup this couple i do um
it's just to me like and i think that
they're so well suited obviously
it's just this level of obsession is
just so unsustainable in the long term
like where are you going to be in 20
years yeah i know but like i i also did
feel that way about like
travis and courtney but they've really
simmered down it's been five [ __ ]
minutes no no i know but like i figured
once they simmered like it would be over
and i do feel like they're still going
hot and heavy but they're not as
annoying like with all their pictures
and stuff but mgk and megan like are
doing
the most still and i think it's because
their relationship is so good for both
of their careers like i know travis
didn't need it like as much courtney
doesn't care like what her career she's
like fine and travis is like an icon you
know but machine gun is like still an
up-and-coming artist megan has had this
like kind of treacherous career where
she was like black wild in hollywood so
i think that like this relationship is
the best thing to ever happen to them
and every time they do something crazy
and weird and like it's even better for
them yeah i agree
i just hope that you know they're not
you know i think it's all very authentic
so i don't worry but you know
if it is so good for them and then that
starts to put pressure on
to keep it up but i think i think
they're very well suited they're clearly
twin flames i don't think anyone could
really dispute that yeah so i just i
wish them a lifetime of love like i want
to see them together until they're old
and grey me too and like i don't know i
just feel like they're a blended family
he has a daughter
and she has kids with
ryan austin green
and so maybe they watch blended and
that's why it's also successful i mean i
did read that on jamaa so also travis
and courtney are blended family yeah and
they're like a real blended family 100
somebody had dm'd me basically because
yesterday we were kind of just
taking stabs in the dark as to why
courtney like wasn't in new york for snl
and like didn't really appear to be that
supportive it was one of travis's kids
birthday parties yeah i said that on the
show oh you did i thought someone sent
that to me in a dm yeah so that now that
i've seen blended i do know how
important that is it's so important i
never expected her to be in new york
um
you know everybody was like writing such
nice captions it was just an interesting
thing but i don't think she's a long
caption sort of girl me neither i don't
think she's like a feely emotion kind of
girl yeah like
especially not for just like an snl
performance yeah she's
her own person i actually really respect
that not everyone can open a vein just
at the drop of a hat
are you talking about yourself i'm yeah
i'm speaking for those of us who don't
just give it all up i feel that yeah you
know and i'm speaking for all of us who
literally meet someone for five minutes
and like show them our vaginas except
like when you write someone like a
birthday caption you write hbd and like
other people write them for you and
they're much more
okay so are you talking about captions
because like i just like cannot i'm more
of a speaker than a writer like birthday
cards birthday captions like my hand
hurts like i don't really feel like
comfortable i speak from the heart in
courtney's situation since i don't know
if maybe she like called kim and said
something i'm just really talking about
captions you know actually you're right
then i don't uh not and it's not because
i don't feel like i know what i feel i
just don't want to write it like i'm too
lazy maybe that's how courtney felt it's
what i'm saying yeah and there's nothing
nefarious going on
well thank god for that yeah you hate to
see it be nefarious you hate
okay our next story a little exciting
music news adele reveals the release
date for her new album 30 details the
album's blistering truths
so as predicted by one miss claudia okay
i can't really take credit for it like i
saw people saying it online okay but
then i told it to margo and she was like
how do you know that and i was like from
claudia no i have like kind of mine too
i have kind of
turned into
this like crystal ball healing like
psychic like i just found something out
and you know what's so sad it's like
okay
so somebody just posted something in our
facebook group they were listening to a
really old episode of ours basically
like back in the day like 2018 2019 2018
we did like a couple live shows we would
record the audio and put it on our
patreon for our subscribers and so
someone was just like feeling bored and
went back to listen to this random live
show we did in nashville where we're
talking about like chris harrison how
like if he just could end the
bachelorette he would be doing us all a
favor like we're so over this show then
we were talking about like well what
happens after chris harrison and i'm
literally sitting on the stage just
screaming jesse palmer like jesse palmer
jesse palmer 2018
so obviously i am a crystal ball healer
but i make these amazing calls and then
i don't remember them so like what's the
point in being able to predict the
future if you can't remember your
prediction but you know maybe it's for
the best because like to have to travel
with all of that information it would
clog up
your internal hard drive that's very
true you know you just you
you set it and forget it so i did say
that taylor was moving her release of
red up from november 19 to november 12th
because of the impending adele album we
didn't know if it was going to be true
until we knew when adele was releasing
her album this morning she announced
it's november 19th and it's called 30
and she looks absolutely gorgeous
beautiful sounding smart side profile on
the cover album album cover it's
everything her first single drops on
friday so excited called easy on me i'm
so excited i'm excited for this era this
is the kind of music i'm just like
needing in my life right now
and
i'm
we deserve this i know we touched on it
yesterday on the podcast episode but i
also just
feel like the point that we made about
her being so consistent with her music
so reliable like even with her album
cover her aesthetic it's just the same
and it's just so nice i love when
artists reinvent themselves i really do
like literally the grammys announced i
think yesterday that
casey musgrave star cross is now
eligible for
uh pop album not country like i for the
most part like when people reinvent
themselves not always but there's also
just something so nice about being a
consistent queen yeah and we're so used
to
these pop queens like for every album
there's a whole new persona and it's
like the instagram gets wiped clean
everything i did before is trash that's
not me i don't know her yeah and here i
am these are my new favorite colors and
it's like
what about just incorporating all those
things that came before into what's next
and it's just nice to see
this sort of like growth from adele that
like we all experience in our actual
lives totally like from breakups
marriage divorce baby yeah it's really
like this beautiful cacophony of
emotions yeah it just doesn't have to be
like oh the old me is dead yeah yeah i
know i feel that 100 and so i when i saw
her album cover that she released i'm
like there's our consistent queen yet
again being consistent yet again so
that's really exciting november 19th set
your calendars um oh and then also
speaking of taylor swift i'm not sure
where it came from but some like
country music blog last night leaked a
demo of taylor swift's recording of
better man now i'm not sure if it's the
recording she make maybe was going to
put it on red the first time or because
she's now putting it on the second time
that's what i was playing before we
started the show it was absolutely
gorgeous like not what i expected
gorgeous harmonies and like i just i
don't want to encourage people to go
listen to a leak but it is on tick tock
if you want to go listen to it so okay i
wish i knew what i was listening to and
i listened to it but i feel like if i
had to guess what it is i feel like it's
what she sent to
little big town right being like i wrote
the song you want it yeah like i don't
know if it's the one that's going to end
up on yeah i think it was like the demo
whatever it is
i loved it like who sings a little big
town yeah yeah and you know what i have
to say i'm very hard on little big town
mostly because
that little blonde one just i don't know
she she bothers me like i can't explain
it um
but what they did with that song is so
gorgeous like it's really something to
behold yeah so for that
there's one point for little big town
one point for me
okay we're even yeah
next episode
i i can't i'm sorry i'm continuing now
it's going to go this way just
next time
next up some exciting space news william
shatner is going to space actually i
think he's there right now um on a blue
origin space flight with jeff bezos so
his historic flight will make him the
oldest person ever to go to space this
comes nearly three months after bezos
and his brother mark and two other
passengers flew in the company's first
space flight with humans on board sweet
this is
jeff bezos is one jeff bezos is doing
another space um because i saw on
twitter this morning like nasa tweeted
out a picture of him and elon musk
responded so i thought maybe it was like
elon's thing no this is a bezos endeavor
and now william shatner's the oldest
person to go to space but i thought jeff
bezos's other thing was like he brought
the oldest and the youngest people to
space and now he's like has to do
himself already three months later
they're just gonna like keep going until
they're like we got the first redhead
with blue eyes who took a dump in the
third grade like yeah they're just like
it's beyond them it's so stupid it's so
stupid but i do love william shatner his
work in miss congeniality one two three
four five six and seven is some of the
greatest i think out there chef's kiss
he was really something and his work in
the priceline commercials i hope he's
bringing that energy to space
you know the aliens will love him do you
think it was hard growing up with the
last name shatner i mean he made the
most of it yeah
he did he's just a mega star he's in
space
and where are his classmates not in
space not in space
until you know then
richard branson is going to come out and
be like well i brought william shatner's
third classmate to space first william
shatner's bully literally yeah so that's
what's going on in the space news it's
getting a little stupid it is but you
know
they think it's cool
you know and it's definitely cool and
someone's having fun with it yeah as
long as someone's having fun yeah but it
seems a little unnecessary but anyways
happy for william shatner and happy for
william shatner um
the happiness that we have for him
is brought to you by pros pro
specializes in custom hair care and now
they also make custom hair supplements
that are personally tailored to address
your specific cause of shedding because
you know postpartum hair loss jacks is
like a huge thing i know and pros is
here for you they take into account
things like hormonal changes stress
levels diet and more the results are
customized supplements guaranteed to
help you grow thicker longer softer hair
in record time they're made with clean
safe and natural ingredients pros hair
supplements are just two capsules a day
daily
the first capsule will strengthen and
rebalance the scalp it'll reduce
shedding and then the second capsule
helps to spark fuller faster hair growth
in the follicle they're free from drug
synthetic fillers and dht hormones all
of their supplement formulas are
gluten-free dairy-free nut-free vegan
and cruelty-free try your own custom
hair supplement and you'll get 15 off
that's uh pros.com toast p-r-o-s-e dot
com slash toast for your free in-depth
hair consultation and then 15 off the
custom hair supplements if you're
suffering from postpartum hair loss any
type of hair loss get a supplement it's
like your hair must it's like an organ
it needs to be taken care of thank you
claudia
it's a pleasure
fifth and final story
is
technically okay
okay
yesterday we opened up a can of worms
do you like the triangles or not
i would say a lot of the feedback that i
got is they like it but
we specifically may sing too loud and it
like busts out their ears so i'm going
to be
taking my construction
down version okay i'm going to move my
mic away a little bit ready and yeah and
keep the triangles just like at a
distance
[Music]
next story about demi lovato
starting drama with aliens
y'all i think that was beautiful
and you know what and that's where it's
like asmr that's where the
constructiveness
comes in with the criticism because i
think that made us better we were
gorgeous you guys will let us know what
you thought and now we're going to do
the rest of the show in a way asmr yeah
in a whisper so what's up um and you
know what i love about the triangles if
i'm in what other shows you know they
have actually they actually have like
music intros and like segways in between
segments whatever and they just like hit
a button and the music plays and we do
that [ __ ] live and i think that sets us
apart
i think
i've never agreed with anything you've
ever said more you know like we are just
we're live performers
it's morning slide show it's morning
shows
live show it's 30 rock live show it's
morning shows live
oh dudes
freaking how many do's can you do
honestly that was just a good reminder
to re-watch 30 rock zach's re-watching
it now
and so sometimes i'll like get a glimpse
of it while i'm making a snack and it's
a pleasure it's literally the best show
it's hysterical yeah okay our fifth and
final story demi lovato believes we
should stop using the offensive term
aliens to describe
extraterrestrials
demi lovato thinks that referring to
extraterrestrial beings as aliens is
offensive according to a new interview
flogging their new peacock special
unidentified in which the disney alum
seeks to uncover the truth about the ufo
phenomena alongside sister dallas lovato
and best friend matthew scott montgomery
lovato explained to australian tv outlet
pedestrian tv last week that quote i
think that we have to stop calling them
aliens because aliens is a derogatory
term for anything that's why i like to
call them ets so yeah that's a little
tidbit a little information that i
learned now i just want to share
according to the online etymology
dictionary alien comes from the old
french alien and the latin
eleanus both meaning strange or foreign
it adds that the meaning quote residing
in a country not of one's birth dates to
the mid 15th century while the meaning
wholly different in nature is from the
1670s and the usage not of this earth
was first recorded in 1920. i just feel
like demi is very confused because first
of all
i think she's just i think they're just
getting conflated because
when you used to call someone an illegal
alien like that is not pc anymore that's
like a derogatory term for someone who's
undocumented we're not talking about
aliens like from mars like
i
this is giving me very much shark attack
energy yeah and i have one thing to say
alien
shark attack like first of all
we don't even okay so this is such a
dumb conversation for a multitude alien
is a word it's a
dictionary like and its definition is
you know not from earth
not
of this earth so let's just let's unpack
because first of all there's so many
things that are stupid about this one we
don't even know if aliens exist so let's
see what there's like a 50 50 chance
that aliens exist so we're like worried
that we might offend something that
doesn't even exist which is like a whole
level of like sensitivity culture like i
can't even get into like we don't even
know if and then let's say they do exist
do they have feelings
i'm sure that they do do you think
aliens exist i you know i think it's
very self-centered to think that of all
the galaxy and all the world that we're
the only
beings right to exist all this stuff
with like ufos and all this recent
activity i did watch that documentary
that ben made us watch
and i've been listening to a bit of joe
rogan and he's very into
unidentified foreign objects yes he is
so
i
i'm open you know
i'm open to believing though it's not
something i feel very strongly about
well it would make sense that like
there's
aliens
oh for sure like there's definitely
something you know i don't know if
they're like organized and like coming
for us but there's something yeah i
don't know how often they have come to
earth
and
but they're aliens i think i think we
could agree on that so back to deming i
feel like there's
like
i don't know what's going on with demi
as it pertains to their career because
demi recently signed with scooter braun
and i was like you know what scooter
braun makes stars and demi was going
through like a weird thing with the
frozen yogurt and like she was just like
not very beloved on the internet and i
just feel like
i don't understand like what
demi's doing like with
the music and like that last album was
seriously like offensive to the music
industry like it was really a treasure
she didn't listen it was atrocious and
like i don't want the demi fans to come
for me i just don't and then she like
demi did like this award show
another award show like talk show on
roku like i don't understand what's
going on and with the timmy's career
they have a podcast now
called 4d
so she's they are really entering into
you know more of a personality
personality and i think what people are
saying is
we don't like your personality oh that's
rough yeah no totally a lot of the times
that demi has spoken about stuff there's
so much to unpack no and there's so much
backlash along the lines of this like
this is ridiculous okay so most recently
like so demi did an interview with
hoda
talking about how uh i think
demi's sister is pregnant
and now that demi is non-binary and she
goes by they them pronouns like demi
doesn't know what her nieces and nephews
should call
them like
aunt or uncle
so this clip went viral on tick tock of
demi being like i think we've landed on
an uncle
because like it just sounds like it's a
combo yeah like
ankle no she's an ankle ankle ankle she
said ankle ankle so it's just like every
time demi does something there's so much
blow back yeah because
they're kind of cringe like everything
that comes out of their mouth is just
like what yeah and i think demi really
thinks that they're doing something most
of the time yes and then everyone has to
let demi no no you're not no i think
demi's intentions like are in the right
like i don't think demi's a bad person i
just think she's like kind of weird and
and like i'm sorry they're like kind of
weird and i don't know like where we are
gonna go from here like she said they've
had such an
interesting year maybe two years from
the froyo thing it's kind of been like a
fall from grace yes i agree so what now
i don't know well
they have this new show unidentified
what's it on peacock
it's a special sorry
yeah so i feel like they're doing just
way less music stuff yeah
i don't know
anyways there's only one thing to say
alien alien i'm so glad you brought that
up oh okay now it is time for
uh
james proposed to raquel and i'm gonna
start with the good news okay because
james and raquel i ship so really
vehemently hard so the episode was
actually really beautiful because they
had a really nice moment i felt so
raquel they were playing on jenga where
you pull out and like there's a dare on
it which was just like so cringe i
literally felt like i was watching
i don't even know what it felt like they
were just all sitting around
doing it i
i can't even explain silliness it was it
was so so dumb it was like wait guys
come here we have to film something
anyways raquel pulled out the jenga make
a toast and she really she froze because
you know that she's so shy yeah and she
pulled something out which was like
totally fine and then later in the night
they were about to take shots and
someone's like raquel make a toast again
and like she really couldn't
get something out it's giving hannah
brown remember i know but then so then
she was like to james can we just like
go outside for a second and she really
like broke down talking about how she's
so shy and she's always trying to put
herself out of her comfort zone and then
she's around like people like
who are so confident and it just makes
her feel even more insecure and then
like a lot of people like lala like put
her down yeah no but she wasn't even
saying like that like she just really
wants to be able to
you know have her brain and her mouth
can match better but she just she can't
do it and it's been like that her whole
life and
she was like aren't you embarrassed of
me like
james was just such a great i was
literally like i had goosebumps he was
every response like he was such a great
partner
and i think they're just so well suited
for each other like you know they're
they are who they are you know maybe
they're not for everyone but there's a
lid for every pot and i really believe
that these two are that for each other
so like because james is like an extreme
extrovert yeah and she's extremely
introverted and i think that they both
admire
in each other those qualities like the
the extremeness
and because they're so different and so
he proposed to her and like i just it
was the perfect episode to explain why
they should be get engaged because i
have i really had no doubts they're just
as
ready to be engaged as any other couple
i've seen on tv and it was really
so
lovely it was moving and i i stan raquel
i really do
she's been on such a journey she's such
a sweet person she's so stunning and i
just like i just want her to know like
you're not embarrassing at all because
it's so sweet a lot of people freeze
when they have to give a toast
and a lot of people give a good toast
but like they're hiding that they have a
massive [ __ ] pig oh yeah yeah
so that was the good news
the rest of the episode was just the bad
news first of all tom sandoval is
single-handedly ruining the show and he
has been for years like even when the
show was good he was always the worst
part of it i wonder now if i went back
and watch the first seasons if i would
load him as much as i do now or if he's
just gotten worse and his head has
gotten too big it's it's the latter like
he was definitely not like everyone's
favorite person in the beginning but he
wasn't like a bad like he was just like
someone like not your favorite character
but now he's like actively chipping away
at the good parts of the show and
they're like building the show around
him his commentary he constantly thinks
he's doing something yeah he's doing
absolutely nothing and like they had
this pickleball
tournament which was really cute and he
would like was all you know
dressed up and like distraught like
everything has to be a theme with tom
like you know and he's just trying so
hard to go viral like so corny i can't
and he was like blowing a whistle the
whole time he's like my tactic is
distraction and
katie maloney who's i'm loving on the
show i know it's just her presence
because she hates him her presence is so
funny because like she hates everything
like she hates all of this yet she's
staying in a house in a palm beach with
in pumpkin charlie like it makes sense
no totally anyway so she but she
participates because she has to and she
was like this tournament was a random
draw and i randomly chose the most
annoying player of all time tom sandoval
like he's like blowing his whistle every
time she serves because that's his
strategy it was just
painful no i really do like katie too um
yeah and i'm just really liking this
energy she's giving us a season because
she's like giving us nothing yeah
because she like hates she's like i she
knows she has to be a part of the show
she i'm sure she doesn't want her like
all of her best friends aren't on it
anymore but she has a restaurant she's
like still very much tied to this group
of people
and
she's like this is moronic this is
moronic but like she's representing all
of us who feel like this is moronic she
represents like the generation of people
who like know what vanderpump rules used
to be and now she's playing pickleball
being like this is so [ __ ] stupid
everyone thinks they're funny and it's
not yeah but you know i love pickleball
i know so it was nice and it was randall
who set it up because he loves
pickleball i think it looks like they
had a pickleball court in their house um
and randall spoiler won the tournament
because obviously he [ __ ] plays every
night
no one else has heard of it before
that's funny um so the tournament was
fine there was some drama between sheena
brock and sheena's mom who is their
nurse and nanny
and sheena pays her
and she's giving very much candace and
chris it yeah
it but it's a really interesting dynamic
because like brock you know he left an
hour early to practice for pickleball
because he's an athlete he's never
played before they bring their kid to
palm springs yes and and so the summer
and ocean met later in the episode which
was a very telling scene but so yes the
mom is there but it's also the mom's
birthday so anyways brock left the house
like um an hour early to practice for
pickleball which i actually thought was
like kind of cute like he's taking it
seriously whatever and everyone was like
upset with him you know he went to sleep
earlier than sheena and he woke up later
and he went to play well if they're
playing a nurse that's right and that's
what he's like saying and but sheena
it's like you know it's not just
it's it's she feels bad asking for you
know any so it all falls on sheena and
it's just a very very odd dynamic and
sheena's in the middle and it's like
it's not good no that's actually like a
terrible if your mom's gonna be your
nurse that's lovely but to pay your mom
is kind of weird yeah so it's just
stressful over there and then they had a
double date with randall and lala they
went over to their house and the babies
met and brock shared you know more about
himself which is that he was
married before
and he has two kids
and he hasn't seen them in four years
and they don't talk
and they um like the kids have like a
new stepdad now and they all live in
australia and
like when lala and randall heard that
they hadn't spoken in four years like
randall's face and they were
shocked why did they say why apparently
sheena said i watch what happens live
like we'll find out more throughout the
season they always say that i just
it's really crazy and he has a daughter
whose name is winter
and then sheena's daughter's name is
lying and then but sheena said it was
always something she wanted to name her
daughter which i believe because i could
see i thought it was madison parks
apparently that was rob's name yeah
but also i could see shayna being
obsessed with the oc and being like i
want to name my daughter summer roberts
yeah so that i believe but
then lala was like imagine you have a
kid with someone she was like she was
like imagine you know and if you imagine
your winter and you hear that your
deadbeat dad had a baby with someone and
named the kid
my name is june and they named the kid
august that's so lala was like if
randall went off and had a baby with
someone and called her lake like right
that would crush me yeah
so it was just it was really shocking i
think that's gonna be like an
interesting uh
storyline and other than rachella
happened oh the only other thing that
was so weird was tom sandoval was making
this whole rachella thing like as if it
was his proposal
and because he like is so extra and i
guess that's his thing but he was
writing all the checks to all the
vendors he like paid for everything at
rochella what like the food trucks and
the acrobats and ever and the fireworks
because they showed it like the vendors
said how much and he and he was like uh
he's like yeah i'm paying for you know
stuff for my friend's engagement even
though i'm bar like putting my house up
for uh collateral he's like because you
could always borrow more money what i
was it was very confusing
it was so weird it was so weird like i
think maybe people think it was like a
nice thing to do for your friend but to
like it was probably around
at least seven thousand dollars and it
looked like he was paying for it and
that is just so weird no that makes
literally no sense none whatsoever he
really like was doing too way too much
yeah with this thing but that's his
thing he's extra no no no no so the real
hostess of beverly hills reunion
starts tonight and i just cannot [ __ ]
wait i can't wait but it's also just no
part one it's part one it's going to be
you know
not much no but the show's not over
because we have two toasters which i'm
really excited about again an abridged
version because i'm a woman of
compromise um and it's brought to you by
zip recruiter you know there are some
things in life that i like to pick out
myself so i know i've got the one that's
best for me like cuts of steak
mattresses bottles of wine so what if
you could do the same for hiring you
choose your ideal candidate before they
even apply that's where zip recruiter
has invite to apply it gives you as a
hiring manager the power to pick your
favorites from top candidates and right
now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
toast how does invite to apply a work
work well when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send you the most
qualified people for your job then you
can easily review the candidates and
invite your top choices to apply for
your job
it's actually a fabulous um
way to go about
the standard kind of traditional
antiquated way of applying for a job
ziprecruiter's internal data
shows that jobs where employers had used
zip recruiters invite to apply get on
average two and a half times more
candidates which helps make it faster
for the hiring process so see for
yourself just go to this exclusive
address ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t
to try zip recruiter for free that's zip
recruiter dot com slash toast zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
thank you claudia
would you say i said thank you they said
cute claudia i'm like thanks
all right dear toasters our advice
segment if you ever want to write in
it's dear toasters gmail.com we'll take
issues you know that you're dealing with
anything we don't judge sometimes we do
but we try not to all right first off
hey guys love you so much congrats
jackie on the new bebe thank you let's
get into it my boyfriend and i have been
dating for four years we live together
and we just got a puppy the issue is my
boyfriend's mom she's a very nice woman
but it's definitely a little odd i'll
explain my boyfriend is one of three
boys so i understand this is partly not
her fault but her wardrobe choices are
awful it's to the point where i have
friends and co-workers saying things to
me last week i had a co-worker come up
to me saying she saw my boyfriend's mom
shopping at the
junior section at target i was horrified
and then the next day i saw the top she
had clearly picked out which was clearly
meant for a junior she's always wearing
really tight short small things that i
would never even
that i wouldn't even wear because i'm
half her age i've never said anything to
my boyfriend before because i don't want
to seem judgy and like i said she's a
sweet woman so i just bite my tongue but
here's where i'm having trouble we were
going to a college football game and she
sent me a picture of the dress she's
wearing to it and let me just say
i would have maybe worn it to my eighth
grade semi-formal what do i do just let
it go her fashion choices seem to have
gotten so much worse over the years and
i have nightmares about what she'll wear
to my future wedding i need some advice
love a conflicted toaster so
i'm struggling because because because
you're a toaster and i don't want to say
something mean but you're being so mean
you're being really [ __ ] i think like
okay the the concern about what you'll
wear to your wedding one day you'll
cross that bridge when you get there and
who cares no like
if it's your wedding you can say what
this woman can and can't wear sure but
in her daily life i think you gotta
leave her alone totally i why are your
co-workers like staking out where she
shops why do your co-workers even know
like who she is it's really mean
i'm not here for this but the woman's
happy it doesn't bother your boyfriend
he's never been like i wish my mom would
wear longer shirts right
i just i'm i'm afraid this one's on you
yeah let it go like let everyone be who
they are yeah and you know what it's
cheaper to shop in the junior section so
yeah it is what it is and she likes her
like and even for like when you guys get
married everyone's looking at you let
her be herself in her dress no but like
this girl was writing and being like my
you know my mother-in-law future
mother-in-law always dresses kind of
weird i never really cared like free
wedding i kind of want her to look just
like more conservative i would think
that you had somewhat of a leg to stand
on like it's your wedding you can decide
what people wear sure like you can give
them colors and and some
guidance
guidance yeah but but this for everyday
life is just mean but i just can't
relate to why you would care so much
like
people be themselves yeah i agree i'm
sorry i'm so sorry
i just needed to hear it from someone
else
and i'm sure that's not what you wanted
to hear but that just like did not
that didn't sit right all right this is
our second and final one good morning
jackie and claudia i'm hoping you can
give this day one toaster oh there's a
bug sorry on this day one toaster some
girly girl advice oh love giving girly
girl advice there's no better sort of
advice two of my good friends are dating
each other and they just moved in
together this summer their names are
chuck and blair blair and chuck have
never had any relationship hiccups and
pretty much are annoyingly obsessed with
each other blair recently found sexting
messages between chuck and another girl
the girl sent multiple nudies and he was
saying things like what he wants to do
to her in bed etc etc
this went on for weeks blair
since confronted chuck and he said all
the typical things that you say when you
get caught how he didn't mean it and
he's sorry within days blair is forgiven
chuck and his cracking jokes about it
and acting like he's the almighty chosen
savior again i'm one of the only friends
she's confided in and i've told her my
opinions that cheating is cheating but
i'd support her in whatever she decides
to do but it's bugging me how she's so
forgiving of this terrible thing she
would have never known about without
snooping was he going to continue this
or have a form into a physical affair
how do i go about this and act like
everything is peaches and cream is
sexting cheating in your opinions
obviously i love them no matter what and
it's not my relationship to get involved
in and i don't know what i'd personally
do in this position but what the [ __ ]
xoxo gossip girly girl
that's funny uh this is like really
disturbing i do think that sexting is
another individual
is cheating because it's emotional
cheating they just hadn't gotten the
chance to get physical yet or maybe they
had and you just it's still cheating it
was unsnoopable even if they didn't ever
that's that's so cheating um
i think you know you give her your
advice you definitely
need
would i would you know advise caution
for her but she's gonna have to figure
this out on her own i mean
that's exactly what i was getting she's
like wants to be optimistic
and
believe that all's well
i'm also sure that maybe she's putting
on a braver face because it's hurting
her more like you're joking about it
then she cares to let on but it's not
good and chuck and blair probably you
know aren't going to end up together
but sometimes people just have to learn
things for themselves like even if your
friends can see it so clearly the best
lessons are learned the hard way and so
if she wants to like be
you know innocent about it and she'll
get her heart broken again maybe then
she'll learn if not and maybe it'll take
five or six more times some people you
can see it so clearly because you're not
involved in it but sometimes people just
have to learn things the hard way and
you can tell her your opinion and she
probably won't listen and then in five
years really oh should i listen to my
great friend who's a toaster right and
so i would just you know be a friend to
her and if she asked your advice
definitely give her the truth
but
she's gonna have to go through this on
her own which is unfortunate yeah
damn but you sound like a great person
yeah for sure what's new with you
literally how are you feeling um so
those were the deer toasters the deer
toasters email is your toasters
gmail.com and i just want to remind you
if you've ever written in and we've
given you fabulous sage
wise advice um and you either took it or
didn't take it we would love to know how
things turned out for you last week we
got literally the happiest ending of all
time about the girl who found adult
diapers in her husband's closet and was
literally like the best thing i ever
read so
dear toasters at gmail for new
submissions and for updates we would
love to hear from you we would love to
hear from you the only other thing that
i want to share before we wrap is some
of the other stuff that i was watching
sure i started this new show made
it's on my list on netflix it's starring
margaret quality and her mom i know andy
mcdowell they're playing mother and
daughter in the show and they're both
amazing actresses so it's really good
that's really cute i'm only three or
four episodes in
and it's a really good show and the
acting is really good it's just you know
it's pit-inducing
so um but one of them a maid or
something so she's
yes she's working as amazing okay it's
really about margaret
got it okay it's her story you know
margaret's like so famous like you know
just like being a hollywood socialite
and like a hollywood nepotism queen um
but i've never seen her any in anything
so i'm actually looking forward to like
watching her act she's a great actress
and i feel like i
saw her as an actress before
like the nepotism queen stuff so i
really don't associate like i think
she's really earned her
these roles no i'm i don't know i don't
know if i'd say earned but i'm sure
she's good no no she's like a serious
actress she was in once upon a time in
hollywood oh was she yeah she's serious
i don't know anything about her she's a
serious actress except like she dated
shia labeouf and pete davidson
and her mom is obviously the queen for
my favorite movie ever beauty shop
yes that's andy mcdowell in my opinion
best work
it's really good but you haven't seen
beach house with her and
layton easter playing a mother-daughter
duo
it's beautiful it's a hallmark film is
it
um okay what is that all you watched um
i'm sure i watched some other stuff that
just
doesn't i'm gonna watch made so like we
can recap it as we move on okay cool and
then um yeah i think that's it i'm so
excited to start a new book i knew
sophie can sell a book is out that's the
perfect
palette cleanser it is what i changed
after what i've been through yeah um
so i think that's all she wrote now now
i feel good about that thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast fast stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio catwalks all the places so every
listen to podcast find nice morning
chelsea if i starve you better beautiful
stun
and smart we are if you made it to the
end of this episode congratulations you
are a true toaster you are you are a
part of the society season two and to
let us know how far you've come in this
episode go to our most face and
instagram and drop an emoji of the
little ticket to honor the tickets for
my tour going on sale it's like that
little red one it says like admit one
you know tickets tickets tickets i would
recommend three drop three of them
tickets tickets tickets love you guys
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye